you kind of process like Buddha would
alright let's go hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even had
her wings and today we're joined by Big
Sean he's a five-time Grammy nominated
rapper and prolific hit maker for more
than 10 years strong
his fifth studio album Detroit 2 is set
to drop very soon and in the meantime
you can catch him on 20's a new comedy
series Wednesday nights on BT big sean
welcome to the show a great intro how do
you handle your heat like if you go to
Sweetwater do you order an extra spicy
water who preps you have you been to
Sweetwater not yet but I hear it's the
best it's the best wings and swings yeah
so today I'd like to give you a gauge if
I eat like I get you Franks you know
what I'm saying
I'm not too much I can eat like Red
Rooster that kind of gets me like
emotional okay
[Music]
okay okay little kick wakey wake me up a
little so one of my favorite details
about your come up is the fact that you
worked as a telemarketer before being
signed at good music yeah did the
demands of that job do anything to
prepare you for the trappings of Fame at
the very least they both require thick
skin and a tolerance for rejection yeah
being a telemarketer sucked you're like
really selling that [ __ ] for your life
you know you're like hey this is hey
this is Sean Anderson calling on behalf
of the but it or whatever it was you
know what I'm saying his script was but
I never I never thought about it
preparing me for what I do now but yeah
I believe in like divine order you know
I'm saying I'm a spiritual do so I
believe that like God prepares you for
your journey you know you and if it's
woody telemarketing job I've definitely
talked to people who would like told me
to go kill myself told me like [ __ ] off
my cuff stop calling me I'm like bro
this is my first time calling you like
the thing is you just let it bounce off
you bro you know you've got to have
tough standing and bounce back don't
take it personal yeah bounce back sky
right here
Somali pika pretty good oh yeah okay
cranking it up a little bit here yeah
that was a big jump
we went from G to like pg-13 which says
the city's native son I know that you
have a deep love for Detroit sports
teams it's not uncommon to see a
courtside at the Pistons game and of
course you were at Tigers had almost
everywhere you go yeah what is it about
Stan Van Gundy that makes him the most
unexpected draw in hip hop because he's
been named checked by you Nicki Minaj
Lil Wayne and that's just off the top of
my head he's passionate he would lose
his [ __ ] like I never seen Steve Kerr
like really good Stan Van Gundy
emotional you know what I'm saying so I
think that's probably why you know hip
hop embraces him a little bit yeah he's
cool for those who don't know what the
Rock's
iearned paradise test is can you explain
it and then was it a big deal for you to
get a passing grade on your single verse
he told me he listens to my music you
know what I'm saying regularly I saw he
started following me on Instagram so I
just like hit him up sent him a song
didn't expect anything from it next
thing I know I go online he's like
working out to it you know what I'm
saying he told me he hit me like he hit
me personally it was like you know a lot
of people send me songs and they're
[ __ ] whacking you know but this is a
this one really helped he was like to
help me get through my workout help me
finish my workout off so he actually is
part of my motivation like I've been on
my own fitness journey myself for like
well over a year now and it's been good
to me do you have an all-time favorite
Big Sean sports reference personally I'm
a major fan of when you rhymed Wells
Fargo with ball until I get a military
oh I'm finally a famous vol 3 man is you
did your research
it's per spekt spective and my favorite
one is if I lose one I bounce back like
two three double four or five because
when I came up with the line I didn't
even realize that Jordans numbers went
like two three four five I mean I never
really thought about it you know it's
one of them like you know when you just
fall into something you'd be like you be
playing it for people to even like man
that triple entendre I'd be like oh yeah
[Music]
yeah you know I'm at that point where
I'm trying to like separate my body from
my consciousness you know so maybe
you've been preparing for hot ones all
along maybe you're right
this is fine mm-hmm I'm good so for
those of us who are naive to the inner
workings of the music industry can you
explain the role of record label in 2020
because sometimes to listen to hip-hop
you'd almost think that labels are like
the sworn enemy of the artist but
obviously the model still remains um
that was a very intricate question I
love my label
I'm signed to Def Jam signing good music
both our labels of my first choice - so
I was lucky enough to do that but I do
think that you just got to communicate
how you feeling because people usually
can see where you're coming from and
when they communicate to you you can see
what they're coming from I try to think
about it by comparing it to other
industries and you know sometimes you'll
see an athlete complain about a league
or Commissioner and every once in a
while there'll be an actor who gets
upset with a studio for killing their
passion project but the town-gown
relationships between artists and labels
it's almost a part of the music news
cycle all of the time whereas that
because there's the artistic
sensibilities of an artist or is it like
kind of a reflection of the industry
like it does seem to be more prevalent
in music yeah it does that's a good
observation but I think musicians are
like expressive too you know and I'm
saying we're like are we have the voice
the athletes do too but it's like that's
what we're that's what we do we express
ourselves so we express ourselves we go
on rants will do go outsourced our heart
is wide opening I made music till I
hopefully inspire people hopefully they
like get them through some or to get to
the next level to get to that better
version of yourself I could see why
artists may be a you know especially
musicians like our passion and and talk
they should you know get it off their
chest
[Music]
I don't eat that much hash it so this is
like think of as a spiritual journey
okay
I like those so it seems like there's
such a vast range in artists maybe you
have someone like jay-z who will be
quiet for years and then they'll come
out with a body of work inspired by what
they're going through in their life and
then maybe you'll have someone like Lil
Wayne who's recording relentlessly and
oftentimes creates out of his own
imagination where do you think you fall
on that spectrum you know people
especially a mentality coming from like
Detroit it's always like you got to stay
consistent you got stay on them you know
what I mean you stay on the necks or
whatever you know like Outkast they
would take like four years sometimes
five years between their projects so
when you imagine you have 1 2 3 4 10
songs 20 songs that people know that our
hits that are platinum 30 songs like I
feel like you get placed in a different
category and that's the category of
longevity that's why I think when people
take the time out like jay-z you know
Kanye
those are guys they could take 10 years
if they wanted to come back and we tuned
in if you like oh hold on before we go
any further can I ask you a question of
course
okay how many seasons has this been
going on believe it or not we are in the
tail end of our 11th season almost 200
episodes what yes Oh congratulate that I
appreciate that 1,100 times up and you
guys got that home you guys got the game
shows yeah we're on TV too so it's just
this dumb idea that we had and then spit
you staying on their necks staying on
their neck striking while the iron's hot
so Wow who came up with this idea so do
you see did you meet Chris butt chin
yeah they're a hoodie so she came up to
me in like 2014-2015 he's like have this
idea what do you think about
interviewing celebrities but having them
eat increasingly spicy chicken wings is
a winner break them down over the course
the interview yeah that's the that's the
story of hot ones are you guys taking
investors do you guys like let people
invest yeah
[Music]
but I'm gonna make it to the end no
problem I'm determined and hey not to
guilt-trip you or put any put any weight
on your shoulders but we did fly all the
way out to Detroit yeah I'm not gonna do
you dirty nowhere so in the fit spot we
have this recurrence segment called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our guests and scramble interesting
pictures that need more context oh yeah
okay let's go so this is you and Elton
John yeah what do you remember about the
night that you learned that Elton John
is a Big Sean fan
well that was at the Grammys and um
Elton John called me on my birthday and
he was like hey man I read an article
somewhere that you're like you know
you're going through a growth in your
life a spiritual journey in your life
man I just want to tell you I've been
through that too
you know I don't know if people ever
take the time out to call and tell you
that you know it's okay man it's okay to
figure yourself out it's okay to you
know and I'm saying take some time and
like you know come back as a better
version of yourself you know so he talks
to me for like he probably was on the
phone for like an hour that day so he's
cool man
shut up Elton John all right up next
what's your favorite thing about ranch
life in Wyoming
besides the four raptors ranch life I
definitely like the alpaca out there
cool out pack a donkey's running around
you see him though like the where he
dropped like all the easies off and
chicano yeah so it's like this tank um
then he has like goes on water and [ __ ]
you can go like in the water and it's
like crazy it's like some military type
vehicle type vibes going you have a good
time out there yeah it's fun it's just
like you music God nature I know I'm not
like smiling that big on that picture
but I'm really happy I appreciate him
he's like forever a brother no matter
how much we talk or don't talk or
anything like it's fine good times all
right and last one for you you know you
are taking no chances in every industry
seems to be dealing with this
coronavirus differently yeah I mean I
was definitely like looking forward to
Coachella being now
you know what I'm saying like being like
Ana I know that you're very excited for
that yeah I was very excited for that
I've been a few times I've came out a
whole bunch of times but this is the
first time I was like you know how much
[ __ ] and I was like I'm ready to tear
[ __ ] down you know what I'm saying
but I understand you gotta be safe I've
been right wiping down my seats on my
plane I've been like a germaphobe I've
been doing that before Korona okay sold
on sure that was the first five first
five down okay five more to go
this doesn't look spicy at all it's
green it's green a Thai chili sauce okay
Carolina Reaper serrano pepper it's
pretty good go for another bite go for
it son no interviews you rail against
clickbait stupid questions and even
those celebrities who leaked information
to gossip sites for their own dark
motives alright if you took over the
editorial direction of a major media
company that covered hip hop what would
you say are some of the more
underrepresented topics when I was
growing up thinking about like okay I
want to be a rapper I didn't think about
any of that type of stuff I ain't think
about like blogs I was just thinking
about I just wanted to make music you
know and you give people music make
people be the life of a party in a sense
you know what I'm saying gave them
something I have fun too and with all
that other coverage all that media stuff
is just like it comes with the job so I
think that if I ran
like that I would definitely make sure
it's very like well-rounded not drama
based you know what I'm saying yeah what
does we think that's higher you you are
you like you you [ __ ] with like hip-hop
for real like you like know what you're
talking about
thank you I appreciate the hell let's
start a site right and like we already
have this interview on Sean that or
with one of the Stargazer
hmm what the it's okay you're good right
I'm good if you're good bro so the great
New York version cago Pizza debate it's
raged and Leslie on this show for many
years yeah Detroit Pizza is like so much
better right we've yet to talk about
Detroit pizza so I'm hoping to get
somewhere in the site where these issues
that Donnellan dom on tissues sounded
some homey cliff he makes like these
homemade pizzas that are like fire Jed's
piece of style deep-dish thank you
appreciate that and um I can feel it in
my nose
we'll be careful around your face don't
touch your eyes thanks for telling me
now
appreciate that have you picked the side
in the great tug of war between American
Coney Island and mafia Lafayette has
really came through for me like almost
clutch the nitesite it's burning a
little bit for Real Steel can you
recommend a Detroit restaurant one if I
just have $10 in my pocket yeah and then
another if I hit the jackpot over at the
casino
um she's spicy that's it let me ask you
that question sure
so you're from Chicago yeah so we're
we're places there like in Chicago
that's like of Chicago now I'm not
talking about like Harold's like I mean
yeah Harold is great yeah Heroes is
great but I'm talking about like to
spend like a lot of money yeah you just
want you guys don't have casinos huh no
no no there's no hittin the jackpot
you just got to go with whatever's in
the checking account but I would save
this like Harold's amazing oftentimes
crave Italian beef when I'm in New York
and then if I come back you know go to
Al's or whatever but then to me the best
restaurant experience that I've ever had
there is that this place called next
okay and I've been to the spot Alinea
like so if you ever watched like season
2 episode 1 of chef's table and Netflix
it's like this crazy sort of like
17 course wine pairing 800 dollars a
plate sort of thing are you trying to
open a restaurant is that what you're
telling me yeah we're still shark
tanking yeah yeah I got some ideas okay
cool yeah so what's this this looks you
going you ready yeah let's go same time
same time same time with this one okay
Oh through
okay no problem
[Music]
tough one right so you're consistently
talked about is not only one of the best
hip-hop artists but in a more elite
discussion about lyricism why do you
think what the fire this this is this
yeah
why do you think Detroit consistently
punches outside of its weight class when
it comes to lyrically inclined rappers
like yourself or Eminem a Royce to 5/9
this is hers bro I got your board water
what cut is Detroit
you know I need some tissues tissues
coming in we also got some lifelines for
you like what we got some yogurt oh yeah
mmm better right Wow yeah do you stay on
top of the new artists that are coming
out of Detroit mm-hmm
so out of baby cash kid Drago be no
whistle at if New York is known for his
response I know
Alissa I'm sympathetic I'm sympathetic
I'm right here with you yeah if New York
is known for its Air Force one's DC for
its Foamposites what is like the uniform
in Detroit car car is a special Detroit
approached it's like Buddha wood
all right let's go
[Music]
fifteen out of ten heat man off the
charts it doesn't even make sense yeah
Daphne regrets about giving out your
real actual phone number on the outro of
dark sky paradise no that was tight
you know how people be like oh you
change types you little [ __ ] I used to
hear that used to bother me for I don't
know what reason yeah I gave my number
out I kept it for a long time as much as
I could but I got to the point where my
phone bill was like through the [ __ ]
roof I didn't realize that you still get
charged if your [ __ ] is just blowing up
like a hotline I [ __ ] with that though
now I love talking to people I love
picking it up and like hearing what
people had to say like pick it back to
that more I need to get back to
connecting with my [ __ ] people bro
well what's your number now you want to
just a three one three eight one five
and you can guess the last four where
did the idea at the last one one more
for you before we get there yeah where
do I go bro where did the idea here but
let's go man where did the idea come
from to sample Pete Weber's who do you
think you are I am on over time cuz he's
a champion bro that's how I was feeling
off recording that like a champion he's
a champ shoutout Pete Weber who do you
think you are
are you okay that's what I like to hear
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
really have to if you don't want to what
do I look like bro huh huh
[Music]
that's good shop now all right that's
good no that's good that's good that's
good yeah I put a little bit more than
you I got three go ahead put some a
little more on there there all right Hey
look you're scared you're in Detroit bro
you can't be scared I'll eat you a lot
here Detroit vs everybody yea they eat
you alive
you ready yeah
come on let's go what a journey it's
been Big Shot yeah thank you
oh I was gonna I was gonna toast you my
wing but sorry in your mouth now sir gas
pedal high gas pedal devil I just want
to look at your reaction before the last
dab you're good you're good I'm just
goofin Detroit goofin alright Big Sean
here we are at the end of the line and
just one more bump in the road before we
hit the finish line at the end of a long
day after the grind I know that you like
to unwind by meditating and watching
movies yes true so I'm the chance that
Rawls self quarantined by this time next
week
we need an entertainment guide according
to Big Show I've heard you say that you
never give a bad movie recommendation is
there a film that you've seen in the
last year that you would suggest to the
people watching right now a lot Jon week
3 and I've seen is crazy Joker was great
parasite was great home so many good
movies
can you suggest a book yes that will
change our life
okay we're on the same page right now I
already knew what you're about to say
the seven spirits a law that says by
Deepak Chopra The Alchemist these are
books that will help you implement ways
of like applying successful traits to
your life that will take you up bro is
this a metaphor for life bro are you
blowing my mind right now it feels that
way it doesn't it life starts the
classic mild at the classic it's kind of
cool it's not too many problems you go
on [ __ ] gets tougher then you hit a
[ __ ] like you don't know if it's make
it happen yeah you might have to cry a
little bit and you might doubt yourself
might doubt your something and that it's
too hard but the passion this is a med
no wonder why this is so successful bro
no wonder why you guys are on eleven
seasons but you know what Big Sean if I
had a crown I'd put it right on your
head there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red card in it man my friend
this camera this camera this camera let
the PA know what you have going on in
your life what I have going on my main
focuses the new album excited to get to
the world man it's been way too [ __ ]
long so thank you world this is Sean I'm
the host of hot ones thanks for coming
out today my guest Sean and it's a wrap
live reporting live from Detroit we did
it
yeah Wow are you guys still rolling I
know it can get tough but okay no citrus
no milk a little yogurt okay we did it
okay hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and as you know you
can catch me every Thursday in this
little black box interviewing
celebrities but what if I told you that
there was a show that actually had a
decent set where we fed even hotter
wings to civilians while asking them
trivia questions well guess what my
friend that show exists and it's called
hot ones the game show hot ones the game
show on truTV check your local listings
we'll see you in the pepper dome
[Music]